this whole like sex sex change stuff  that they're talking about right now was  transgender right  um hey you know what's wrong with it you  should let them do it you should let  them go through it you know what's wrong  with a kid wanting to do that and hey if  the parent agrees and approves to they  should let them do it  some of that stuff for me is the brain's  not yet been fully shaped to make tough  decisions like that in your life that  should come later on to me uh to make  some of those things introduced to kids  like hey now we got seven billion  different pronouns to go to school and I  gotta my kids gotta come and say my one  of my classmates today said they have a  pronoun they want to be called this what  is that that I don't want to have those  conversations with you I just don't and  the public school has made the mistake  of allowing that to be normal and  they're taking a hit for